the minimalists are once again going on
tour this is our tenth tour in ten years
it is called the les Coast tour will be
hitting eight cities across the west
coast of the United States and Canada
for more details head on over to the
minimalists comm slash tour we'll see
you soon animists hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist merry Christmas everyone this
is coming out Christmas Eve and so I
thought it was a perfect time to talk
about some of these sort of especially
in today's modern world the internal
conflicts that many of us experience
when it comes to community and
individualism when it comes to reason
and spirituality when it comes to to
religion and atheism on Christmas Day
we're gonna talk about this
perfect timing yeah and we're here with
today's guests Eric Weinstein is here
Eric thank you for joining us thank you
guys for having me you're awesome and
thanks for being here I really
appreciate it I did not know that we
were doing the Christmas special given
that this is early November you forget
to wear your saying hi exactly well who
better for a Christmas special than an
atheist Jew
okay new ground here minimalist well you
know what was fascinating how we first
connected and I actually wrote down the
very first tweet I sent you and I said
that we often hear people say that they
are spiritual but not religious but I
often feel the opposite impulse I feel
the impulse of like I don't feel
spiritual in the sense of the the woowoo
or the mysticism but I feel the impulse
of like religion or at least what
religion often brings to us and I heard
you say somewhere that you are an
atheist who happens to go to synagogue
every weekend well not every weekend
well that's a lot of weekends goes to
goes semi-regularly semi-regularly
and and I found that that fascinating
because you're on this podcast we've had
a lot of different perspectives we've
had
pastors like urban McManus who runs a
mega church across the street from here
we've had Sam Harris on and sort of
everyone in between and I think we're
all yearning for some of the same things
we have similar values but we get there
via different paths in a way and I was
really intrigued by by the fact that
well okay maybe you don't believe some
of this you don't have the same beliefs
as some of the people in your synagogue
or I don't have the same beliefs as many
of my my close Christian friends but I
think we have similar values you wit so
I hope so
but I also believe that we don't even
know what people believe who are in our
congregations or even leading our
congregations I think that the idea that
somehow our picture of people who are
devout religiously motivated who are
regular attendees to some house of
worship that these people deeply believe
is just fake that's not true they
struggle yeah they go in and out what
their belief means is not entirely clear
as for the line that I'm spiritual but
not religious that sounds like a bad
pick-up line yeah I don't know just like
you're trying to appear interesting in a
bar yeah and you try and make sure you
don't hit any tripwires
I think that part of the religious
impulse is about community yeah and one
thing I find hysterically funny is that
all of these people who are fiercely
against anything that strikes them as
tribal or organized go to a lot of these
weird human potential movement meetings
and say what we really need to do is to
find some way to build community and
ritual into our lives I'm thinking you
really haven't made the connection yet
have you that that thing that you were
so focused on distancing yourself from
is the thing that you are now yearning
for right and having a hard time
replacing like the word tribal lots of
people just that's the end of an insult
channeling you're seeming a little
tribal
now and I'm always thinking like a
little I mean I hope that I'm fairly
tribal and I am so in an adaptive way
and then I'm not so in a in a murderous
or jingoistic way but there's nothing
wrong with tribal dog because I think
that's where where ideologies become a
bit of a problem when when Dogma is
attached and it doesn't allow our
beliefs to be to be fluid in a way right
and I think that's maybe where a lot of
people have a problem with organized
religion as they feel like if I don't
adhere exactly to these beliefs and
that's why I was really encouraged when
we had Erlin on orwen McManus on the
show you know he's he's a pastor of a
very large church but he I think one
fifth of his congregation are atheists
yeah yeah and it made me realize like oh
you can have different beliefs you don't
have to subscribe to a particular doe
let's begin with the concept of being a
sinner can you manage that part of the
adherence can you just say I'm a sinner
yeah because once you get transgression
against the belief systems into the
equation you're in so like maybe you've
fallen off the wagon you're aspiring to
something but you know you hit the
bottle you had a crazy weekend you can't
quite remember okay well you're in the
religion you're a sinner you recognize
your own imperfection and I think that
that's really a key part to belonging is
recognizing that there's no way you're
gonna follow the rules as they're stated
their aspirational they're not intended
to be some set of rules which if you
can't follow it you're out because then
no religion would have any adherence
yeah in some cases they are right I mean
Ryan grew up Jehovah's Witness and yeah
I mean I left because of the dogmatix
because I got to a point where I was
looking at the it wasn't inclusive it
was actually exclusive even though you
know the the whole organization that I
was in they say oh we welcome everyone
and anyone can join but it's as long as
you follow these rules as long as you
you know take on these this specific
type of dogmatix and just do anything
that you like no no no it yeah I mean
I'm sorry what what
what I'm what I mean is we can all
accept what I came to the realization is
that we can all accept that we're
imperfect but to exclude people based on
very trivial dogmatix is where I
couldn't buy into it anymore so so yeah
I mean it's funny because you're hitting
the nail on the head with when I left I
had this tribalism that was missing from
my life and for ten years I have been
really kind of seeking and I didn't
realize it until recently actually
seeking a community of open-minded
like-minded people with similar values
not not necessarily beliefs but just
kind of all supporting one another
heading in the same direction when it
comes to whatever Life brings us for me
like I've been able to find like I found
this men's group that kind of has this
community but there's no dogmatix
associated with it but I think that's
where I don't know the dogmatix I guess
what I'm trying to get at is what really
I think starts to exude people and and I
and I don't I think there are some
people you need to exclude from your
lives but there's a balance really
important I don't know why inclusion has
gotten such a great name first of all
almost anyone is talking about inclusion
if you actually scratch the surface
they're talking about exclusion almost
immediately right right yeah in order
for my people to be included you guys
have to shut up so it's really
interesting that you have a movement for
like diversity and inclusion that
instantaneously tries to make life less
diverse and more exclusive then you have
all these other weird things you can
just notice in your own mind so for
example if somebody advertises we are
going to be going to an inclusive public
eye island on this trip
that's not compelling but if we say
exclusive private island suddenly people
are willing to part with money uh-huh
right oh he had a public chef oh no no a
private chef are oh that's really
interesting
so in the same breath we have to look at
our own hypocrisy and realize that
exclusion and exclusion go together
there's no way to separate them so
just the way you know I often talk about
promoter and repressor being things that
live on our chromosomes to either make
more of a protein or less of a protein
to keep something from being transcribed
every religion and tribe has inclusion
and exclusion functions and they have to
otherwise they wouldn't exist right
right so there's nothing wrong with
exclusivity what we measure is on what
basis did you exclude yeah and I love
that man so there's a balance that we
need to have with inclusion and
exclusion well this is the weird thing
like you know there's this this little
bit in ecclesiastes that somehow we
forgot and I talk about it a lot these
days because in the 60s there was this
song turn turn turn I guess you know the
beat the The Byrds and Pete Seeger and
company you know just brought from
Scripture and it talks about that
there's a time to kill you know what a
time to refrain from killing or whatever
it is we can't even talk about that now
because we it's that hippie sentiment
about there being a time for every
purpose under heaven is now under
assault like we now feel like there is
never a time to exclude there's never a
time to kill there's never a time to
silence there's never a time to shame
well that's nonsense the key issue is
are we doing these things in an adaptive
way this is our tool kit so like you
know shaming and canceling I'm against
cancel culture but I'm not against the
idea that some people have to be removed
from society
by making them pariahs because they're
really evil I just think it's a terrible
idea to advance than anyone you know to
the right of Bernie Sanders has to be
you know excluded from polite society
that's ridiculous yeah well I mean when
I think of exclusion where I think it's
harmful is like my dad won't talk to me
right now because I'm not a Jehovah's
Witness
I live with my my wife I mean we're not
we don't have the piece of paper but I
mean she's my life partner
we don't really see the value in getting
married we're not traditional we're not
religious but there is a point where
exclusion
well it's not adaptive is is kind of one
but ask yourself what does he think he's
doing like if you take if you've ever
read John Gottman's theories of couple
do you know this guy mm-hmm either of
you let me recommend him to you he he
had the crazy idea to set up a an
apartment rigged with cameras and
microphones and then to invite couples
to spend the weekend and he would figure
out well what is it the couples that
stay together actually do so he has all
this data I talked about this right mmm
calls it the love lab uh-huh
okay well one of his great ideas is to
try to figure out how our dreams are
getting us into trouble and how our
instantiations our strategies are not
the same as our dreams
so you give us a beautiful example about
a couple that fights incessantly over
how neat the house should be mm-hmm and
it turns out that they have the same
dream of having a creative life but one
of them grew up in a stifling house
where nothing could be amiss and that
person wants creative space too to mess
things up and to be creative and the
other person grew up with Bohemians and
the house was so out of control that it
constantly weighed on everyone else in
the family so nobody could accomplish
anything okay so what if you instead of
thinking about marriage or the fact that
you left the the order or whatever
mm-hmm
you just abstracted it away and said
okay what is my dad's dream mm-hmm that
he and I would be part of a shared
narrative mm-hmm a shared tribe that the
piece of paper to him may mean that he
knows that there are lots of forces in
the world that pull people apart
let me just say something from your
dad's perspective you don't know it I
would love to see more from his
perspective so I try to okay so the
whole purpose between husband and wife
right as it is a concept now we have
same sex marriage but let me focus on
the traditional case is that those words
were distributed with universal meaning
so that the resident in everyone's head
as to what a husband means something to
wife mean something
and what he was hoping you do probably
was that you would step into that
mimetic complex of ideas that is shared
by so many people and then like you know
if you go into a hospital and you say my
wife is in room you know 312 mm-hmm that
has more power than saying my partner is
in room 312 or my girlfriend is in room
312
right and so there's a way in which what
he's really asking you do to do is to
participate in some larger structure not
to rob it of meaning by saying it's a
piece of paper you know a piece of paper
from the government I forget what a I
think there's a Joni Mitchell song where
she talks about we don't need a piece of
paper from the government well it's
funny cuz I do refer to her as my wife
as I did when I had said hey I'm living
with my wife right now we don't have the
piece of paper but I do consider her my
wife but for him it is it is the you
know the definition of what a marriage
is and that is a public union it is a
you know the government gets involved
and says yes these guys are husband and
wife which is a strange thing because
that wasn't I mean the government wasn't
involved when you when George Washington
was married right it was a it was a
particular agreement and maybe even a
religious ceremony but but what's the
other thing I often says I I love my
wife so much I didn't feel compelled to
get the government involved and and it's
gone the same way like Bex and I don't
have a piece of paper that say we are
happily ever after or whatever but but
we do have a an actual contract and we
meaning we have an agreement with each
other
and also we have things that that to us
are far more important like life
insurance for example to me that that
that is much more of a commitment than
going down to the courthouse and yeah I
think that what I'm picking up is is
that a lot of us have these fears about
these inherited structures right so like
marriage is an inherited structure your
religion is an inherited structure and
because our inherited structures are
failing like almost universally across
the board at this moment due to some
some stuff I've talked about on other
podcasts the key question is
should we be spending our time saying
I'm not getting sucked into that or
saying man does that institution need
help and we're just the people to do it
and you know the just in your case I
didn't hear any pain coming from your
agreement but in your case you have a
variable that is open to you when you
want to use it may not work I don't know
your father from Adam and I can tell you
that you know the the particular
religious order you're talking about is
famous for being pretty fanatical right
oh absolutely and I guess - and this is
really going by yeah actually the reason
I say that is because if they cancel my
copy of the watchtower Ryan let me just
say this real quick I know I think
Eric's being very charitable toward your
dad but just knowing the circumstance
here is I think he uses religion this
particular religion as a weapon with
which he batters you and if he didn't
have the religion there would be some oh
yeah weapon 100% use to batter you and
control you in a way yeah but I guess
because this is going back to exclusion
sure where everyone in the community of
his church is saying good job Eric
you're doing the right thing you should
not talk to your son
you should not so it is that's really
why I bring it up is it's this idea of
exclusion where yeah you're right like I
think that yes we should be as inclusive
as possible but to your point there are
absolutely people who I exclude from my
life I'm not gonna hang out with you
know the homeless drug addict on the
corner because we've got very similar
values and very similar things we have
going on in our lives
I will exclude people like that from my
life but I was just you know kind of
giving the example of where exclusion
can be really harmful and actually I
think if we get into the voicemail
questions Peters question I wish I was
just the thing I did right before this
was hanging out with homeless lady who I
don't know why I got into a conversation
with her you know she's trying to save
the world it wasn't entirely confident
that she was stable I don't think that
that's true you might hang out with that
person I think
yeah I think that what's going on is
deeper which is that everybody's hurting
we're all in these injured familial
relations I think that as we come to
understand families we realize nobody's
got one that really functions right like
families are meant to be messy and up
and tortured and ridiculous
dysfunctional by default dysfunctional
without exception I don't know of a
functional family yeah I don't know you
know there's that famous beginning of
Anna Karenina about all happy families
are exactly alike that show me one right
every family has misery and I don't
think that's an accident I think that
there's no other way around it you know
Continuum's obviously oh absolutely
nothing well and you the nice thing you
really you do with your podcast which by
the way is called the portal I would
encourage folks to to listen to it if
you tackle some of these things that
quite often in the mainstream we're not
even allowed to talk about anymore or
they have become very recently become
taboo subjects and you you you grapple
with it I'm gonna talk a lot more about
that but this show is a a listener
driven show so I want to dive into a few
questions we have here the first one is
from Isabella in Chicago my name is
Isabella and I'm from Chicago and I am a
sophomore college student and I just
realized that all my high school friends
have found has moved on from being high
school friends and I was wondering how
to move on to those relationships and
make new ones so Eric since we're
talking about community today sometimes
we move on from one community to another
now that might be because we've changed
geography you changed geography recently
you moved back to LA after what 30 years
away
37 oh okay what prompted the move back
defeat no I don't know it's not why
people usually leave LA no no no I left
because it was a living hell
it was it was the worst city on earth I
felt I heard you talking to Bret Easton
Ellis about yes and you both have I love
that conversation on your podcast with
so Bret Easton Ellis for those of you
who don't know him he's sort of the
original well not original Raymond
Carver
by the original minimalist literary
figure but but he's the guy who sort of
popularized it with with less than zero
and eventually American Psycho that that
sort of style but he a lot of his books
are very sort of la centric even the
ones that don't occur in LA feel like la
as a character or at least tangentially
a character but you two had radically
different views on on Los Angeles sort
of I mean I guess I should say that he
became famous for taking the seeds of
this weird high school experience where
we both graduated in 1982 turning it
into a book and amping it up and I
didn't even think to do that because
this I just thought
first of all nobody would ever believe
what was going on in in this place at
that time exaggeration almost but it
sounds like it wasn't but you can go
back in time right you can look at the
billionaire boys club
you know the idea of rich kids murdering
parents I don't know the Menendez
brothers from the time the the serial
killers that that it was just and you
know the the statistic you should always
look at is number of divorces per
hundred thousand women after no-fault
divorce went into effect in 1970 and I
think it was when Ronald Reagan it was
divorced signed it into law it was a
terrible and weird time to be growing up
now in retrospect there was a lot that
was cool because it was so bad like
death and destruction it just always
leaves a residue of cool it's like why
people watch war movies and play war
games and things and so that the the
carnage in terms of broken teenage lives
and things and you know really bad
things happened I think in retrospect
looks cool if you survived it but I
don't think it was a good place to grow
up now that said the city has always had
huge positives many of them are secret
you know I think it's a much smarter
town than anybody's ever giving la
credit for
not just because of like Caltech and
UCLA and things Iran corporation I think
that you know getting back to your your
your well I think right now la is the
place to be for a new movement which is
the podcasting particularly long-form
podcasting revolution is capitalizing on
the collapse of what I've called the
baby boomer bubble where really was
started by the Silent Generation and
then carried on by the baby boomers and
all of these belief complexes that were
held by those generations are now
crashing because they're nonsensical and
they've been nonsensical for almost 50
years so it's a really good time to be
in this cauldron of people who are using
this format to get out things that CNN
and ABC and NPR won't touch now with
respect to the other question about
community first of all with your high
school friends there's a period of time
where they go into hibernation to some
extent yeah so Ryan I've we've known
each other since we were fat little
fifth graders okay but after high school
he sort of went his own way he got
married at like 18 yeah and I went out
to the corporate world and he was
working for his dad and like we just
sort of there was a hibernation period
is fascinating yeah well that's the
thing is I would say a lot of it had to
do with me being in the religion yeah
cuz you were worldly right yeah and
that's why I got married to was because
but I had other friends who were also
worldly where we are Pass yeah
bifurcated after high school right yeah
so I think that when you have a
community that's super I don't how to
say it but the thing about your high
school friends is that you always go
right back into where you left off no
matter how many years away I'm finding
that out yeah having been away for
almost 40 years and I really I I ran
away from this place so fast so hard
that I really didn't keep out of my
relationships and and they're still
there so try to figure out when you
expect those relationships to click back
in and don't worry they're not gone it's
just that now you're gonna make a bunch
of let's say college or work
relationships after high school and
they'll be there for you but those
people are also building the next stage
of their life developmentally and just
don't worry I think don't worry quite so
much recognize that people are going to
be occupied but the relationships are
are there they're just underground I can
tell you that almost all of my closest
relationships there's a few exceptions
to this almost all of them 38 now almost
all of them I made after age 30
including my wife including Jordan and
and Jess I just because we took a
different path after we left the
corporate world and there are some
people who sort of lingered it but a lot
of those initial relationships were
birthed on proximity and convenience and
there's nothing inherently wrong with
that but just because someone shares the
cubicle next to you doesn't mean it's
it's the most appropriate relationship
for the rest of your life either I
disagree with that tell me I know what
I'm about to say sounds wrong but I
[Music]
[Laughter]
actually isolate that let's just start
every podcast with so I always give this
puzzle you go for a family wedding and
you get put up by your third cousins who
you have barely any interaction with
because that's how the the couple is is
parceling at rooms okay while you're
staying with your third cousins there's
a sewage breakage breakage on the second
floor raining down and it's an emergency
it's disgusting everybody's pitching in
right my claim is you will be closer
with your third cousins after that
incident than you are with your first
and second cousins because something
significant happened to you all yeah
yeah and so all that proximity stuff
here's here's this word right it wasn't
just proximity it was proximity while
super important life of
were happening coming-of-age events you
know so you're thinking like oh my god I
may have overdosed or our friend's
girlfriend is late with her period what
happens next or you know who knows what
there's stuff happening
that's super salient important and
transformational and so whoever you're
around when that stuff happens
don't knock proximity yeah now you're
gonna bond over those experiences for
sure like I think about growing up in
high school you're the only person I
hang out with from high school and then
your brother Jerome yeah but other than
that the high school friends I don't
have anymore it's we just our lives went
in two separate directions we have
different values we or we have different
things going on in our lives however
growing up in that religion as being you
know one of Jehovah's Witnesses there
are friends I have who went through the
same thing that I went through leaving
the religion having these same
realizations that I'm very close to
because we have this common experience
of leaving the religion if it wasn't for
that proximity yeah like I don't know if
I would have had such a strong
friendship with my here's a question so
you're probably aware of like the ex
Muslim movement the oh yeah okay
yes you know I somebody takes off the
hijab and they renounce their religion
and suddenly there are no they're an
apostate yeah and they're being shunned
you see this in Mormonism where people
lose their lose their communities yes
and I would say that a lot of
left-of-centre politics is behaving in
the same fashion the idea is that once
you're outside of the bubble and you
know that you're being exposed to
different information sources people who
are convinced that the bubble is life is
goodness they are very worried that
you've gone outside and had experiences
that are causing you to question now my
question to you would be how close do
you feel for example to an ex
Scientologist or next Muslim or an
ex-mormon
yeah I that's a good question I actually
have had very meaningful conversations
we have a friend who's the next Mormon
who would be viewed as an apostate and
her and I share a lot in common so it's
not just with the organization I was
just speaking to
proximity thing that you know that you
mentioned like what the friends that I
have
who left the religion not maybe the same
time I did but eventually they left the
reason why we are in touch is because
we're you know going through similar
things as far as our parents how they
treat us how other friends we had who
were still in the organization how they
treat us but otherwise it him on the
street or met him at a party I don't
know if I'd be friends with them if we
didn't have that shared X so for the
proximate because we were you know
shared the same proximity and we shared
these very emotional experiences it has
secured some friendships that I have in
my life right now yeah the one thing I
would say to your audience is I I don't
share the feeling that just proximity is
a problem I think proximity particularly
when you're going through life
experience is I value a lot of those
early relationships who just happened to
be like whoever lived next door whoever
I I carpooled with you know we are
agreeing violently here because I think
the point I was trying to communicate
with respect to proximity is the the
most meaningful relationships aren't
birthed from proximity alone yes
they require something else whether it's
shared values whether it's an inciting
incident a life-changing incident
something like that Isabel I'm going to
send you a copy of our book everything
that remains might one of my favorite
lines from from that book is and this is
a really appropriate for the time you're
going through right now well my favorite
lines is you can't change the people
around you but you can change the people
around you
meaning obviously we often try to change
someone like I'm going to force you to
yo your values to align with Maude I'm
gonna force you to behave like me you're
gonna have the same interest that's why
I'm a minimalist Josh said he wouldn't
be friends with me anymore works out
really well and so you can't change the
people around you but you can't change
the people around you meaning you can
start surrounding yourself with with
people or seeking out people who share
similar interests or similar values to
you even though they might have
radically different beliefs so Shawn if
you could reach out to Isabella send her
but if you want the audio book if you
like our podcast you'll really like the
audio book version of everything that
remains it's my favorite thing that
we've ever written or if you want the
book book or the e-book we're happy to
send you those as well Peter from
Florida has a question hi this is Peter
a Stinson from Ave Maria Florida I
wondered if you guys saw a
correspondence between what Pope Francis
has been saying and your philosophy and
what I mean by that is I know that that
you each of your different religious
views and that you were a previous
seventh-day or not sorry not seven see
Jehovah Witness and I wondered if you
saw what Prentiss has been saying about
a throwaway culture and the need to move
away from that to one that actually
values human life and human dignity and
what you guys are saying and why you
think that so many people around the
world especially religious and spiritual
leaders are speaking to the same problem
that you guys are saying so yes we do
have a throwaway culture now I'm sure
it's I don't know it seems like maybe
throwaway culture is even the wrong word
but like everything has become even more
ephemeral especially in the the digital
age I don't know whether not that's a
good thing or a bad thing to me the
throat like the literal throwaway
culture is is is bad for a lot of
reasons where we're throwing away
instead of repairing replacing fixing
the things it's much easier to click one
button and have something shipped to you
for next to nothing same day but yeah we
are in a throwaway culture a we're in a
time of ephemerality but also I like to
embrace the via the ephemeral everything
is ephemeral on a long enough time
we were talking about this beforehand
Eric buying a house is we say we buy a
house but do we really own it it's
totally fake it's a different form of
renting it is and you asked I've asked
us if we own this podcast studio and
it's like well sort of like we pay rent
in here every month and other people
can't come in here
well it's funny that old Cat Stevens
line Lord my body has been a good friend
but I won't need it when I reached the
end right so the idea is that even your
body is like that really yours just
someplace where you where your soul
resides for a period of time so did you
want to say more on that was interested
where you were going where you're going
all right I think we're in a very
different weird place I think that you
want we have a hoard away culture and a
throwaway culture at the same time so
we're mourning things that should be
thrown away or never purchased and
that's confusing us because the amount
of stuff that comes into our lives
very often isn't determined by us like
somebody decides to give us a gift we
don't know how to integrate it into our
lives somebody decides to hand us a
piece of paper which immunizes them from
liability but it's not meant to be read
by anyone and yet there we are holding
it so there's all that kind of weird
dynamic happening I think that the
biggest problem with this is we need an
archival sense in our lives that's a
natural part of being human and one of
the things I'm very disturbed about is
that you have to make the ephemeral
archival so if you think about
Shakespeare Shakespeare is tied to the
language of his day you know or Chaucer
you know for example if you go back to
the middle in English and you know won
that approval with the shorter so to the
draweth of March it's passed it to the
road to which sometimes you have to
learn
okay well Chaucer is just trapped in
Middle English you can't get out and we
love him for that right because if we
know any Middle English it's probably
the opening lines of the Canterbury
Tales
when Paul Simon is singing the 59th
Street bridge song he's saying these
feeling groovy which is like a weird
thing to say if you're 20 19 is very
ironic or you know Jimi Hendrix singing
foxy you know or she's a 20th Century
Fox by the doors all I don't I grew up
girls were foxy but I don't know that
they're foxy anymore it's sort of the
nature of language right so here's my
point about about ephemerality you want
an archival version of the ephemera that
was your time so that when people look
back on your time they've got some
honest copy of what was peculiar to your
time but built to last right like there
is something about the 59th Street
bridge song which is just classic and
clean and simple and beautiful and
open-hearted and we're gonna put up with
the word groovy we're in fact we're
gonna love the word groovy in the middle
of that song because it's it's so weird
right it's part of the time capsule and
what I think is is that we don't have
the archival stuff that we need right
now happening in our lives the
complexity of our time has not been
understood by people inside of our time
I think you could argue that there were
people in the 60s who were following
what was going on in the 60s I don't
have a really good sense that what is
happening now it is tearing our country
apart our family some part the entire
planet is descending into these protests
nobody's exactly sure how something in
chilles is linked to something in the
Netherlands the whole thing doesn't make
a lot of sense and nobody's worked it
out and our music is not the music of
our time I'm convinced of this you're
saying contemporary music is not the
music of 2019 well that the role I
should be able to see myself dissolving
into my phone like the smartphone is
having a huge impact much more than the
Erie Canal but like there ton of Erie
Canal songs or you know with the car
when the car liberated us you know to be
independent
you get a ton of car song you know Jan
and Dean type stuff we're getting some
of that now though who who is the gal we
we recommended a few weeks ago was a
Caitlyn Tanner
she has a song called cynical and it's
really it's essentially about these sort
of endless scrolling I Ryan and I will
often say scrolling is the new smoking
and and it's just it's become this habit
and I think I think some there are some
kids now who I say kids your people
under 25 who are are and music starting
to deal with that but maybe also to to
upend your point
maybe podcasts in many way are the new
music well that's that's sort of where
I'm at I believe that when it comes to
this time and trying to do an archive of
it you're gonna have people who are
going to study the podcasts of this
period because that's gotten closer but
I really think that the music needs to
condense down like you know if I think
about you know Country Joe and the fish
doing feels like I'm fixing to die rag
about the Vietnam War mmm
I haven't really heard super effective
songs that took over the country that
complained about all the things wrong
with the trump presidency hmm yeah I
mean there are some albums out there I
can name but I understand like nothing
that has swept the world lake those
older songs swept the world up near
example does a better job of narrative
storytelling and kind of you know the
best of it is archival but I think you
know III asked Sean Lennon I was a
friend of mine to write a song of now
and he wrote the song called boomerang
baby with the Claypool Lennon delirium
with Les Claypool and it talks about a
lot of these issues of ephemera you know
she's never dated anyone before a
thorough search of Google the only time
she's found in church she'll be
attending her own funeral or something
like this I think it's it's a worthy
attempt but I think what we need is we
should have the best effing music right
now with all the things that are going
like the music should be as good or
better than the 1960s I think maybe part
of the problem there is the ephemera
they no longer do we Ryan and I we've
been doing this experiment screen 'less
Saturday's where you know we don't have
a phone on Saturday there are a few
different ways you can do it but when I
first started we had to go down to
amoeba music here and like I bought a CD
to play in my car because I didn't have
my phone with me like the whole
intention was locked the phone in the
drawer on a Saturday and then you know
you see if you can survive without it
for 24 hours it's like the worst episode
of 24 experiment and and and what I
realized is like there was this process
that that didn't have the same ephemeral
feeling the temporary feel where you
went to the CD store the record store
you bought the record you yeah there was
a tactile experience and now infinity is
in my pocket and and I have the paradox
of choice in my pocket as well because
there are 50 or a hundred or 700 new
albums that came out last Friday and yes
the algorithm might serve a few up to me
but even then I'm not as invested in it
I can say you add that to my library add
this one to my library add that to my
library but how much time am I actually
investing in in listening to this music
much less what depends what's going on
in your life I agree with you about the
tactile sensation and the you know don't
even get me started about Tower Records
over on Sunset Boulevard which is where
I had my musical education because the
people behind the counter were
musicologists and right then just
professors right that was a community in
and of itself well but these things were
conspiracies man like jazz was a
conspiracy hmm when nothing else was
going on jazz was happening it was it
was it was you know filled with life it
was brilliant it was coming out of a
place that wasn't supposed to have
intellectual brilliance right the idea
that all these you know black Americans
were doing things we couldn't even
imagine Wow
I mean I was this is you know the sort
of the feel of Ginsberg
how'll you know you're tapped into
something that is beyond for me blues
which I'm a little bit downstream from
jazz I can't quite go that hard
analytically I'm just not smart enough
but blues has this much more soulful
aspect of it that was a conspiracy you
know I remember going to clubs where I
did not feel comfortable I think that
whole thing is gone because you know it
was rejected by the black community that
it's bonded embraced by the white
community so I was in a transitional
area where I'd see BB King on you know
two adjacent nights and one with a black
audience and one with the white audience
and wasn't in any way the same show the
black audience felt like we are a part
we're doing the show together we're
gonna cry out and interaction the white
audience would clap politely when it was
done I got deep in my weeds what we're
talking about ephemerality yes in this
throwaway culture okay so the question
is what's happening when that song is
playing what is the event that happens
sorry I've been talking about this event
which I want to get back into the public
consciousness I'm gonna keep doing it
about 1981 going to see the Rolling
Stones and watching this guy get booed
off stage you know that opening act that
George Thorogood and the Jay geils Band
and then this black guy in a trench coat
in like lingerie and bikini briefs in a
Telecaster and it was you know I keep
saying it's the second coming of Jimi
Hendrix and you know 50,000 people just
hated this guy and turned out to be
Prince and and it was to two days in a
row that they booed him offstage I
believe and I went to both of these
shows and why is it because it was
ephemeral but it was an event but it was
also expectation the reason he gets
booed off stage is the crowds
expectations because they were there to
be titillated sexually by Mick Jagger
and they weren't putting it together
that they were already weirdly
homoerotic Glee open and suddenly this
small little black guy
comes in and I mean this I remembered
like remember this guy because the
guitar playing is just to next level
and that was an event that was something
that happened that wasn't just the
performance of a song and so what I
would say is is that when something
happens like I never even you know that
song he came remember you done done me
felt it you're so chill and my heart
didn't melted you know Jason I forget is
that yeah I can't wait no mama
yeah yeah yeah that song was playing
when I was ice skating with my daughter
and I may not know all the lyrics I
never purchased the song I will never
forget that that song exists because of
what was happening that attached to that
song in a way that was a sort of
archiving of your experience that's
exactly right and it's some of the stuff
that you know I always when I when I
meet people who are really interested in
the music of earlier times don't make
this mistake that you're gonna shun the
music of your era or whatever the music
of your era is attached to that because
you're gonna want to have a time stamp
about what was happening in the world
there's something magical about all of
the music that came out between 96 and
98 for me because that was a period of
time where where you know I was
post-pubescent but still a teenager like
everything was sort of the world was a
new place and that music I still listen
to it now that it archived a period of
my life in it now if one of those albums
were to come out today I'd press to like
this seems weird and out-of-date but for
that moment it created that that time
capsule and in a way the this archival
sense the sense of well you mentioned
hoarding and and also what I would call
Spartan ism which by the way both of
those are forms of obsessive compulsive
disorder right so Spartan ISM is I can't
stop letting go of stuff hoarding is I I
can't let go of anything and I think the
archive and this is probably where we
agree here on the archival side of
things
when done well that actually allows us
to let go and move forward
well they choose the things that really
matter from your time right and that's
that is what's different because now
it's everything is archived and
everything is archived you're not
archiving any well what I do have
started to do I'm not very successful
but being a minimalist but what I what I
have been experimenting with is taking
photos of things and then throwing the
thing away because what I really needed
the object for was to be able to
recreate the memory like I forgot about
that right and so it's just like don't
throw away the card catalogue of your
own mind yeah right when my mom died
this that's what started our whole sort
of minimalism journey I had to deal with
her stuff in one of the ways I like go
of it I realize like oh she was holding
on all these things because all the
memories are in the things but then wait
a minute like she hadn't been using some
of these things for decades there were
things in boxes that were taped up and I
realized she was trying to hold on to
memories but the memories aren't in the
things the memories are inside us but if
we take photos of the things we solve
the triggers for the triggers sometimes
it's not quite as powerful and as potent
so you have to make some kind of a
decision
but I think that none of us are figuring
out how to lead these really novel
worthy lives very well at the moment I
think that there's something about even
if you don't have a smartphone everyone
around you is influenced by the
smartphone it's micro chunking our
attention the number of people I know is
that confessed to me I can't read a book
any longer you know I make the joke I'm
still able to get through even the
longest of tweets but it's hard for me
to watch a movie without thinking about
oh I'm gonna check my phone just
impulsively I mean yeah and yet really
long form television has been the come
out of nowhere success story right the
Chernobyl's and those types if you don't
just give me season after season of
super complicated plot lines right and
that that forms community because
strangely everybody's engrossed in the
same
I can't tell you what it's like not to
have been part of the Game of Thrones
universe and just watch conversation
after conversation he descended to this
you actually you were excluded because I
haven't watched Game of Thrones either
riot Ryan has and so I do feel excluded
from that but I also it warms my heart a
little bit to see that there is a sort
of loosely knit community around
something like that it becomes an event
in a way that yeah well it's it's
gathering around a shared commonality
well it's not just that it's the it's it
builds a mimetic complex so for example
everyone who went through Seinfeld
together now uses particular episodes
and concepts that came out of that show
and really crazy thing is is that we
Jews went from doing her stuff in the
synagogue to saying well at least let's
take all of this learning and put it
into canned humor so jokes that have a
ton lytic punchline and then we stop
telling kin jokes there's like only only
dads do that right well the weird thing
is how much wisdom got lost because that
the joke was the vehicle right and the
wisdom was was the payload right there's
a lot of those jokes were deeply
meaningful my family just traded the
punch lines of jokes we didn't tell the
jokes we told the punch lines because
you already knew everyone knew the joke
nobody wanted to hear yeah and Outsiders
didn't know it right they wouldn't
understand if you're just telling the
punchline that was my father's job he
would tell the joke others right well
Peter I'm gonna send you a copy of our
book minimalism live a meaningful life
we talked about the five sort of
foundational values that Ryan and I
often talk about and you you were
talking about the the ephemera and us
throwing away things and Ryan and I
basically identified you know what was
important to us and some of those things
were actually things but minimalism is
the thing that gets us past the thing so
we can make room for life's most
important things which are rarely things
they're they're rarely the physical
thing you're you're aware of the irony
here
everything we do is steep tonight okay
well the idea that somebody's going to
talk about throwaway culture and too
many objects that you're gonna send them
an object awesome we want the ebook
which we or audio bromley recommend yeah
you can always delete it later all right
before we get into our added value
segment and our listener tips today it
looks like we got a bunch more to talk
about including some surprise questions
we know how to declutter our houses but
how do we declutter our desires how do
you differentiate what you truly believe
from what you were taught to believe how
can you believe in something like
religion even if you have doubts how can
I stop judging other people for their
religious beliefs that I find to be
silly and does a universal morality
exist
plus we are also gonna talk to Eric
Weinstein about truth and are there some
truths that we need to suppress if so
why we're gonna talk about parenting our
parents you know you've heard the saying
when the student becomes the teacher
well sometimes the kid becomes the
parent we're gonna talk to Eric about
what he calls structural nonsense we're
going to talk about the portal his
podcast but also what does that mean
when we talk about the portal when we're
entering new portals we're gonna talk
about comedy and how it illuminates some
of the life's most profound truths we're
going to talk about Eric's risk avert
izing model which is a different way to
think about advertising that might
actually align with minimalism and we're
going to talk about so much more with
Eric Weinstein if you want to hear all
that
listen to this week's maximum episode
available exclusively on patreon that's
right you're currently listening to our
weekly minimal episode but each week
Ryan and I and our guest record an
entirely different much longer maximal
episode and we'll probably go for almost
two hours on this one here where we we
do it on our private podcast it's called
the minimalist private podcast and that
gives us the space to talk about the
things we don't usually discuss in
public it's a it's more of a private
format Plus patreon is the best way for
us to fund this podcast and keep it 100
percent advertisement free when you
subscribe to the middle most private
podcast on patreon you'll also receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you can find all the details and all
the good stuff including additional
private podcast episode every week over
the minimalists comm / support I know
it's just a couple dollars but that goes
a long way for us by the way we are
capping our patreon audience at 6000
patrons so you can get in now while
there's still time and here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners hi Josh and Ryan this is
Claudia in Santa Barbara I have a tip
that I thought of when Josh was talking
about his mostly empty filing cabinet
because I remember my mostly empty
filing cabinet I realized that this tip
might be a little regional and not be as
convenient or available to everyone but
many banks offer a low-cost or even free
safe deposit box for their customers I
keep all of our important papers and
things like birth certificates will
passports and social security cards in
the safe deposit box at a bank less than
a mile away from our home I replaced my
mostly empty filing cabinet with a small
clear accordion file that holds copies
not originals of what has been the safe
deposit box along with one of the keys
to the Box taped inside those hard
copies are mostly for someone else who
might need to know where the original
car but another set of copies is saved
digitally on my computer another tip is
that at that same Bank they will take
bags of paper to shred so when I have
more than a couple of sheets I just take
them in and ask them to shred them for
me
hi this is Amanda from Bloomington
Indiana and I have a small tip for maiya
from the episode 202 by once I purchase
food for two people now since I live
with my fiance so I started to notice I
was spending more in my budget the way I
found to keep the overall cost down is
to plan out your dinners and meals for
the week not necessarily meal prepping
ahead of time but just planning out what
you want to make every night this helped
me get in and out of the store while
avoiding picking up extra unnecessary
snack items and having a menu helped
encourage me to cook at home it also got
me more excited about the actual act of
cooking so I started looking forward to
cooking at home instead of coming home
and dreading it and then end up buying
something out alright y'all thanks again
to Eric Weinstein for joining us today
please check out his podcast it is
called the portal we'll put a link to
that in the show notes we'll also put a
link to his Twitter handle Eric our
Weinstein and follow him on Instagram as
well we'll be linking to him from our
own Instagram account and real quick
four right here right now here is
something that's going on in the life of
the minimalists if you head on over to
the minimalists comm we have a new page
it's called our resources page you can
click the resources at the top there and
over there you'll find a bunch of free
resources that we want to help you
declutter your life simplify your life
make your life more intentional we have
a 30 day minimalism game calendar we
have a bunch of different wallpapers
including our new our new wallpaper
scrolling is the new smoking
they've did such a great job with that
we've got our love people use things
wallpaper our minimalist wallpaper and
our five questions to ask before buying
wallpaper several other wallpapers over
there as well we also have a free ebook
11 writing tips for you that you can
download for free and a longer ebook
called the minimalist rulebook 16 rules
for living with less we have a values
worksheet that's gonna help you identify
your values and much much more of less
over at the minimalists com just click
on the resources page there at the top
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast leave us
voicemail four zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or send up
a memo voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com slash the minimus
if you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists comm you'll also receive our
simple Sunday emails and for our added
value this week let's listen to our
friend Canyon City he has a new single
out called okay and it is a beautiful
song that reminds you that everything is
going to be okay if you leave here today
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening yo
we'll see you next time and minimus